son gohan a character that has been the
focal point of many of the most iconic
moments in all of Dragonball an enraged
chosen one that once led the charge of
the next generation in the series sparks
that hinted towards his potential in the
beginning became explosions of passion
in defense of his fallen friends and
while he has one of the most well
documented falls from grace in the minds
of many fans as of late we have noticed
signs that indicate that very spark may
have returned so how strong is son gohan
well let's have a look I'm totally not
mark and this is the power level series
episode 5 son go on Christ not again
look I have your episode written it it's
done but just like the androids you had
no official sources giving you any
numerical value I do have your level but
in order to make sense of it I need
Goku's full power level in Super Saiyan
3 at the end of Dragon Ball Z so I
decided instead of spoiling a major part
of this series I would hold off and
include you when we have that figure
revealed at the right time okay dude
whoa
look I have pudding here does that help
I literally can't believe that worked
anyway
son gohan is a half-human type earthling
half saying hybrid he's 24 years old
when you take into account the roughly
one year he spent in the time chamber
his techniques and transformations
include the Kamehameha the masane Koh
blast Super Saiyan transformation and
his ultimate form there are nine
officially stated power levels for Gohan
those being 710 1307 one 981 two
thousand eight hundred one thousand five
hundred over ten thousand fourteen
thousand and finally two hundred
thousand and so with that it's time for
some good old-fashioned mental
gymnastics this story begins right after
the transition Toriyama made from
Dragonball to what is now widely known
as Dragon Ball Z cradled in his father's
arms timid quiet and shy we get our
first glimpse at five-year-old son gohan
who if you don't know was named after
Goku slate grandpa Gohan however all is
now well as Raddatz snatches Gohan from
Goku's arms at this point Gohan's
resting power level is won and while
during that brief period he displayed
readings as low as one when his loved
ones were in danger his power
skyrocketed to as high as 1307 Frost
viewers and readers this was our first
introduction to a huge pirate of Gohan's
character his rage boosts sudden and
oftentimes enormous power increases
surge - Gohan when in severe distress he
would lose control of his senses and cut
loose however once came down this huge
power increase would vanish as suddenly
as it appeared from the ranat saga to
the seine invasion piccolo takes Gohan
into the wilderness to train him the
goal of this was to remove the enormous
amount of self-doubt in Gohan's head as
well by instilling him with a sense of
Independence and fighting ability he
catches on really quickly and in doing
so once he lands in the battlefield to
confront the invading Saiyans has
boosted his power level to 981 which
when you take into account the fact
Goku's power level was 10 when he was
twice Gohan's age it's incredible to say
the least however at this point it's
impossible to measure his true potential
and ability accurately largely due to
his power readings despair having been
muddied by either rage or fear the
clearest reading at this point has been
981 and even their arguments can be made
that this isn't an accurate
representation of what he is capable of
either saying that while there is an
enormous improvement
- his altercation with Raddatz he is by
no means confident when his power level
reading was taken it's also worth noting
that Vegeta doesn't regard these as
accurate readings stating Earthlings
have the ability to alter their battle
power which has been proven to be true
something interesting I noticed during
the conflict with Napa was Gohan's
developments softly becoming more and
more confident three instances Chronicle
his development in this department
the first being when both piccolo and
krillen set up Gohan to blast nappa
Gohan however succumbed to his fear and
ran off the second when piccolo grabbed
ahold of Napa's tail once again setting
Gohan up for the attack the trouble this
time was not on going on but
misinformation on Piccolo's part go on
quickly reverted back to being scared
there after the final and probably most
memorable comes after piccolo sacrifices
himself in defense of Gohan with that
incentive go on for the first time takes
the initiative on the attack the effort
was to no effect but the difference this
time was that afterwards he didn't
appear as the same scared child this
particular miss ankle blast reached as
high as 2800 in power this newly found
confidence is most prevalent when Gohan
tries to defend his father from the gia
who at this point in the story let's
face it would scare pretty much anybody
with that over with it's important to
note that once the events of the same
saga are over and go on is about to head
to Namak accompanied by krillin and
Bulma Gohan has undergone two zenkai
boosts the first being when he is
rescued by Goku from nappa the second
obviously once he recovers from the
injuries after the Saiyan saga resulting
in a power level of at least 1500 once
he touches down on Planet Namek at this
point the only two markers of strength
improvement come from his rage boost
that he's had in the series thus far
those being against Raddatz and the Miss
encode directed at nappa these however
are too different to compare the first
was a burst of pure emotion the other
was more focused and calculated both
angry guests but to varying degrees a
conversation between nappa and Vegeta
shed some light on this quirk Gohan
seems to have simply put Gohan is an
extraordinary case due to his mix of
Saiyan and human biology the human side
provides the emotional spark necessary
for the sand blood to boost his power
translation I've got no [ __ ]
reference
and as if Gohan's power at this point
wasn't difficult enough to pin down once
on Planet Namek he meets with guru who
are locks his sleeping power we've
established in my previous video
detailing credence power through the
series that guru sleeping power unlock
works on a slow release they'll spawn a
time go on phases gold Oh his power has
risen to over ten thousand and fourteen
thousand by the time he confronts Riku
during his battle with the ginyu force
once again Gohan gains a zenkai boost
after Goku arrives with the Senzu beans
we can then fast forward to our last
official reading of Gohan's power as we
see him face to face with the evil
tyrant Frieza
standing at a power level of two hundred
thousand with all that said these
official readings had given me nothing
to work with in terms of what he is
capable of wild training despite having
tons of official reference dotted
throughout the series so far but alas
let's put our best foot forward shall we
and try to find something here alrighty
so if we take a look at this quote we
learned that Frieza is surprised by
Gohan's feat of strength he just
displayed it's worth knowing that second
form Frieza is over 1 million in power
level and although this does very little
in the way of damaging Frieza he must
have been way over 200,000 when
launching this attack as we know Gohan's
power levels skyrockets when he loses
his reason and things are starting to
move so let's take Gohan's last rage
moment and use it to develop a
percentage boost when angry fighting
nappa Gohan was 981 but boosted to 2800
when mad that's an almost 3 times
increase so looking at the level of
attack Gohan launched I think
multiplying his current power level of
200,000 by 4 is fitting giving us a
power level of 800,000 but again like
before I would imagine quickly revert
back to normal once he is camped the
attack was enough to put a couple of
scratches on Frazer but not nearly
enough to damage his second form which
clocks over 1 million looking at this
quote it's very important to note that
Vegeta was able to go toe-to-toe with
first form Frieza who has an official
power level reading of five hundred and
thirty thousand meaning his power level
at this point in the series must be in
the region of five hundred and thirty
thousand also thus giving credence the
idea that in that instance Vegeta was
weaker than what going outputted by a
substantial margin padding out my
argument nicely Frieza continues to lay
into Gohan until he is at death's door
however critter
in the nick of time and distracts Frieza
just long enough for Gohan to be healed
by denday giving him yet another zenkai
boost all right so this bit is important
this is where I try to discern a powerup
for Gohan Zheng Kai based off of
contextual evidence in the series thus
far there's tons to consider from Vegeta
being scared at this time to go on being
supremely confident and of course who
can forget the walking sense of being
that is denday this is going to be kind
of fun to try and explain alrighty so
what do we have for certain we have this
quote from Vegeta and the first thing we
should observe from this is that this
boost is referred to as something you'd
expect of someone with say in blood so
Vegeta seems to view this increase as
typical for a Saiyan but what does that
mean what is a typical boost for ass and
that's recovered from near death well
let's have a look for reference we will
use what Fujita's experienced with Zheng
Kai boosts that are confirmed by
official sources after his fight with
Goku on earth he went from 18,000 to
24,000 which is a 33% increase after his
fight with Zarb on anomic he went from
24,000 to 30,000 a 25% increase
therefore from Vegeta's experience we
can discern that the average growth for
a Zheng Kai boost is somewhere in the
region of 25 to 33 percent however and
this is important in this passage Vegeta
describes the increase as steady
whereas when describing Gohan's powerup
he uses the word greatly so go on
getting more than the average Zheng Kai
boos here could be justified so that's
something to keep in mind when we move
forward with this mini investigation
there are instances where Vegeta's power
goes up astronomically where even he
himself states that it wasn't a
run-of-the-mill increase that said he
does mention that this boost could be
connected to fact that they are nearing
Super Saiyan level and really there is
some evidence to support that I mean we
have official sources that back up the
fact that sans increase in strength
dramatically around this level I mean
look at Goku he also got a similarly
massive boost once he got out of the
tank going from ninety thousand to three
million from a single zenkai Vegeta
during this stage of the saga was
particularly terrifying Frieza even
contemplating fleeing from the battle
all together however once did shetan
noticed the increased Gohan received
once he had been healed by denday he
seemed much more at ease stating that
look could be turning our wave just a
little bit keeping in mind that
narrative Lee speaking Gohan is now
stronger
and Vegeta but weaker than second form
Frieza with knoweth our platter more
exact power level
let's put Gohan right in the middle
between Vegeta's 530,000 and freezes
over 1 million with a power level of
750,000 he arrives back at earth with a
power level of roughly 750,000 or
perhaps more depending on whether or not
go hannes power continues to creep
upwards this quote from Frieza lends
some credence to that idea actually it's
important to notice here that Gohan
doesn't go back to help Goku with final
form Frieza like he did in the anime and
Vegeta also doesn't beat up Gohan when
they get back to earth these meetings
were exclusive to the anime and since
they were not part of the manga are not
factors to consider in future
calculations by the time Trump's arrives
Goan hasn't trained in over a year
therefore it's fair to assume that his
power has stayed the same if not dropped
the tiniest fraction I will keep him at
the 750,000 mark due to the drop being
insignificant he is still not fully
grown and his power could have continued
to rise a little after he returned to
earth in preparation for the androids
invasion Gohan goes off to train for 3
years with both piccolo and Goku and
once again I have no means of
calculating how fast Gohan will gain and
strength over those three years
anybody's seen a theme here from this
quote we learned that piccolo is
stronger but given his power at this
time to be well into the hundreds of
millions as we've already previously
established in my last video it doesn't
exactly help much it just tells us that
God's power lies somewhere in the region
of 750,000 to over 100 million which
doesn't help at all
Goku at this point is insanely strong
comparatively - Gohan however that only
becomes the case once he utilizes the 50
times power multiplier that Super Saiyan
brings against Frieza he was 3 million
but once he turned into Super Saiyan his
power shut up so forego on his power
would need to be in the region of about
1 to 5 million however because I have no
way of deriving a figure here I will put
his power again right in the middle act
2.5 million he trained for three years
with the two strongest beings in the
universe Goku and piccolo prior to the
chamber and his body is approaching
adolescence so it's not beyond the
realms of possibility when you consider
some of the feats previous characters in
this series have had one observation I
would like to point out also is that
Goku was three million when he first
attained the Super Saiyan transformation
it's never been stated in this series
specifically however if anger
is the trigger that will leashes the
form perhaps it's fair to assume that
there is some strength threshold one
must pass for it to work I'm not just
trying to blow smoke here either
strange things happen when a saying is
approaching this level of strength it's
observed by Frieza who verbalizes this
numerous times
Vegeta knows is this regarding both
himself and Gohan and objectively it's
observed ones Goku gets out of the tank
this would also provide reasoning as to
why go who didn't change into a Super
Saiyan when Crillon died back in Dragon
Ball I mean he was insanely angry back
then also now there's the obvious
counter-argument that Akira Toriyama
simply didn't plan for there to be a
Super Saiyan until much much later and
this is true however the various
statements by Frieza and Vegeta
regarding all of the active Saiyans
leads me to think that accurate Orianna
subtly wanted to convey this during this
arc because if not why were those
statements even there in the first place
so when considering this
it adds factors as to why Goku believes
Gohan is fully capable of attaining the
Super Saiyan transformation when he asks
him to train in time chamber alongside
him goku knows that Gohan has untapped
latent potential yes but more
importantly he knows that Gohan is
approaching the level he was at when he
transformed so with absolutely nothing
concrete to go on this figure I managed
to find I hope satisfies at least some
of you out there once Gohan and Goku
entered the chamber
Gohan with the power level of 2.5
million grows achieving the Super Saiyan
transformation through harnessing the
correct mental state Goku notes that
this happens really fast again this adds
further evidence to the idea that 3
million could be the minimum requirement
for transforming into a super saiyan in
a couple of short months with goku he
raises his power levels significantly
and transforms let's say he raises his
base level to 3.5 million in missing a
power of 175 million while in the super
saiyan state some more time passes and
once go and has mastered the form enough
to comfortably train in it
goku remarks at how fast Gohan is
improving stating that he might become
quote really incredible I think it's
worth explaining at this time that there
is more to the Super Saiyan
transformation than simply Super Saiyan
one two and three there are in fact
grades between 1 and 2 4 to be exact
Super Saiyan grade 1 we all are very
familiar with this is the form Goku
attained when fighting Frieza for the
first time on Nemec
Super Saiyan Grade two we have seen with
Vegeta when fighting second form cell
there is a marked increase in strength
note that this is not a new
transformation this is a refinement of
the current Super Saiyan form using it
more efficiently
Super Saiyan grade 3 we have seen by
both trunks and briefly in the time
chamber with Goku this form further
increases the power output of the grade
to form with a significant drop in speed
Super Saiyan grade 4 or full power Super
Saiyan is complete mastery of the form
most importantly the users are capable
of maintaining this state with virtually
no loss in stamina all that said once
Goku and Gohan emerge from the chamber
they both have full mastery of the Super
Saiyan form attaining Super Saiyan grade
4 once out Goku and Gohan stopped off a
corns to get a quick read on whether or
not Goku can beat self he boosts himself
to half power leaving Gohan stumped but
the rest of the guys in the look code
are in all even Vegeta
I think this line is indicative of Gohan
in that moment being capable of boosting
his power level higher than Goku go on
at this point most have a power level in
the region of 1 billion when going
all-out perhaps even a little less but
Gohan's character never does anything by
halves so I've highball this one now
some of you might be wondering how I
derived this estimate well I tried to
get it based on a few factors from
previous videos we have discerned the
piccolo and Android 17 have power levels
of around 360 million at this time
fighting first form cell piccolo stood
no chance when he confronted him the
second time now remember I have very
little to go off of in terms of concrete
official reference so bear with me here
Android 16 was able to go toe-to-toe
with imperfect cell stating that
according to his calculations his power
is equal to cells meaning he was
substantially stronger than 1718 and
even piccolo at this time so for the
sake of moving forward let's put him at
400 million I assumed this level based
on the fact that 17 was able to evade
and struggle against cell's efforts
initially it's not the same as when
someone is twice as strong as their
opponents so 40 million above seems kind
of accurate he was dominating 17 but 17
was able to evade for a short amount of
time 2 this would mean that cell would
have a power level in the region of 400
million also once he absorbs Android 17
imperfect cell would absorb his power to
his biomass his absorptions seemed to
work on some sort of addition skill thus
explaining why he would be wiping out
town after town adding power to his own
here's a fun thought if the figures I am
stating are true
that would mean if the average shoe in
power level was 5 taking into account
children with lower levels as well as
others with higher levels cell would
have had to absorb around 80 million
humans to get to 400 million that's some
santa-claus levels have traveled to find
people right there so going off what I
just said there that imperfect cell was
around 400 million and we have deducted
that cells absorption is different to
Piccolo's merging and simply adds the
victim's power to his own we can discern
that semi-perfect cell if what I found
above is true must have a power level in
the region of 760 million so efforts
from piccolo and 16 do absolutely
nothing to him this is more of an
indication of someone being twice your
strength scenes like this don't happen
unless someone is a substantial amount
of strength over you heck with would
generic blast he blows off half of 16s
face once he eventually absorbs Android
18 his power surpasses the 1 billion
mark reaching 1 billion 19 million
capable of pushing it higher when going
all out but let's round it to 1.1
billion for simplicity sake in the video
so therefore given that Gohan at this
point is the strongest fighter but Gohan
is still weaker than cell currently
Gohan doesn't have much in the way of
training before the cell gains and
doesn't re-enter the time chamber again
once Goku forfeits and asks Gohan to
step in
Gohan believes Goku wasn't going all-out
and again is surprised after finding out
that was the extent of his father's
strength once we apply the Super Saiyan
2 multiplier of x to that power level
becomes 2 billion at least at this level
Gohan is almost twice as strong as cell
whom I estimate to be somewhere in the
region of 1.1 billion earlier I don't
think anyone who is watching this
doesn't already know the general theme
of this fight cell gets victimized and
embarrassed at the hands of a Gohan that
has just exploded with anger after this
fight 7 years passed with Gohan either
training sparingly or not at all now
that we're well into the Buu saga we
find this quote and while this isn't a
lot of information we now know for
certain that Gohan has regressed
somewhat in his normal state to say he
was fighting far far better let's say
he's currently fighting with a super
saiyan to form output of 1.5 billion
give or take
making his base form 15 million meaning
since the days of the cell games go on
has lost at least 3 million off of his
base power level with this current
battle power Gohan is weaker than both
Goku and Vegeta who once again
Gohan kicks majin buu once be
for being blasted into the middle of the
forest where he remains knocked out
until he is picked up and transported to
the world of the Kai's to have his power
unlocked by the elder Kai who was
trapped in the sword at this point it is
unclear whether or not go Han receives a
Zen Chi boost from being healed by
capito it's mentioned in super that
after a point they don't apply anymore
however that point is a gray area to say
the least
the elder Kai unlocks Gohan's abilities
and Goku is simply blown away the elder
Kai goes on to say that he no longer
needs to go into his Super Saiyan form
that it's the quote wrong way
fast-forward a whole bunch and we find
ourselves with Gohan versus Super Buu
who has a power level of roughly 8.8
billion
once Gohan unlocks his ultimate form he
attains a power level I've measured to
be in the region of 13.5 billion
now this figure Believe It or Not has
rhyme and reason behind its madness
however like majin buu I need Goku as a
Super Saiyan 3 to derive this figure and
as I've stated before I don't want to
ruin a perfectly good video if I can so
I apologize if this isn't satisfying for
you as I usually show my process that
said once I cover Goku I'll reference
this area of Gohan in detail chronicling
exactly how I derived this figure it
just so happens that Goku is a vital
part of scaling most of the characters
in the series however with all that said
this is the absolute strongest he has
ever been including supers run to date
for the vast bulk of Dragon Ball super
go on plays a secondary character living
out his life the way he is always wanted
in peace furthering his studies and
raising his family he fails to train up
until after the resurrection of F Ark
where he doubts that he can even turn
Super Saiyan which I honestly had no
idea how to measure in any discernable
way over the next couple of Arc's Gohan
is more active and is even seeing
training with piccolo in the new opening
to the show the main piece of info
that's worth taking into account is that
Gohan is now seen regaining his ultimate
form whether or not this is definitely
going to be the case is still to be seen
another telling fight occurred while
Gohan was fighting lavender in the
exhibition match for the two xenos
there go on went toe-to-toe with a
second strongest fighter in their
universe there are many factors to
consider that made this match close the
most poignant of which being the poison
lavender implemented with that taken
into account it's fair to state that
Gohan is significantly stronger than
lavender again looking at the current
opening for the show we clearly see
Gohan unlocked some form of clear aura
this at least to me points in the
ultimate form being reached once again
by Gohan
which is honestly great to see the
Auckland form I will treat as a steady
level of 13.5 billion but if you think
he is less than that at this point then
that's your prerogative I know this was
a long video guys but there was honestly
so many factors I had to take into
account when writing this go on has
officially stated power levels but the
only instance he trained during the
first hundred episodes was during the
span of time between Raddatz and Vegeta
and there was virtually no means to
derive a training multiplier based off
that information with that said I tried
to find as many reasons to justify the
increases while trying to stay in line
with a narrative of the show all that
said thank you for sitting through for
what is now the length of a short movie
if you enjoyed this video it would help
a lot if you let the like and if you
would like to see the continuation of
this series don't forget to subscribe
this has been the power level series
I've been totally not mark and as always
thank you so much for watching